this next email starts it's from Matt
listening to your podcast over in
Australia and loving it my best and
oldest friend we go put me onto the
podcast and I am grateful to him I
wondered if Ralph could pass on a
message to Wigga for me as charlton
heston I've been keeping this a secret
from him for 10 years but now it's time
for the truth to come out
so wait he's he's written a secret he
wants you to read as Charlton Heston yes
why do people keep using us I think we
made this may be a new service we can
offer no we could charge for this if you
have a deep dark secret you want to
reveal to someone you love send it in
and I'll do it in a character yeah maybe
it makes it easier if you hear it like a
wacky voice yeah yeah like a war was
gonna tell you at cancer here tell me
I'm cancer is Dudley Moore how long do
you think you're going to live run there
is very Vanessa
shorter than you think he's going to be
seriously yeah I'm not going to
this very short life there's something
in sighs you and not a penis this time
no you have cancer do you tell me that
it's deadly more I'm ready man I'm ready
- I'm ready gasps through all those
acceptance stages ago right to
acceptance work for Hobson yeah yeah he
went in that movie yeah the first one
not the second no not that one anyway so
this is the deep dark secret - we go
from Charlton Heston we go from Matt we
go ten years ago when we lived together
you were trying to nail a hot chick
named Linda but never got anywhere well
one day you went to work and I hopped
into bed with her and fooled around it
ended with me giving her a pearl
necklace and I made this sort of easy
sorry we go
[Music]
you
[Music]